I haven't won a championship that's the
ultimate goal to win a championship a
lot of people see a lot of potential in
me so just gotta go out there and make
it happen
[Music]
when I was a little kid my dream was
always to I'll be a soccer player
actually I wanted to be president of
Cameroon and basketball was never in my
place mainly because my dad wanted me to
play volleyball mainly and it's not
until I turned about 16 years old that's
when I started playing basketball
[Music]
first game that I watched was the finals
in Boston against the Lakers you know
just watching Kobe that's how the Lakers
became my favorite team and that's how I
fell in love with basketball just by
watching Kobe at the time I was actually
getting ready to go to France to you
know try to become a professional
volleyball player and from there I was
like you know at that time I think I was
13 or 14 years old and then from there I
was like I like that that's what I want
to do because it was just fun I was
looking at it in a way that I thought it
was fun I didn't know how hard it would
be to make it to this level but yeah
that's basically how I started
the journey from Cameroon to the US
everything just happened so fast you
know from you know starting to play
basketball at 16 and a couple months
later I get the opportunity to come to
the state and then I get to the state
and you know I don't know the language I
don't know how to speak English you know
I've never been away from my parents you
know since you know I was born so it was
a big change but you know I had to make
a lot of adjustments and one thing on my
mind was always that you know I'm here
for a reason so got to take advantage of
it
I'm actually my own agent so I feel
proud about it to have been able to you
know whether it's negotiate my last deal
and you know make some of the decisions
and be really in control of my life but
you know I've had a lot of help
when you start talking about learning
business the great thing that I got
going on for me is that I got great
people around me I got you know great
Mentos you know one of them is micro
Rubin is really helped me a lot you know
as far as you know learning a business
you know teaching me the right things I
made it to the league at 19 years only
three years after playing basketball and
I think the main thing why I've gotten
so much better so fast is because I
I'm always listening I always observe
and you know I just take it all in one
of the main advice that is always giving
me is that you're never going to be done
if you got a question ax it doesn't
matter how dumb you think it is just go
ask
when we start talking about endorsements
or you know you know stuff that I've
done business-wise the thing for me is
that you know whatever the idea is I
feel like for me the most important
thing is that I gotta relate to it I
gotta see myself in it I feel like yeah
like I'm gonna be willing to and I'm
gonna be happy to be you know part of it
I gotta be comfortable because if I'm
not comfortable there's no point because
if I just do something just because I
get paid there's no fun in it it's just
like oh you come in and do something but
it's like I don't want to be here
man my legacy wanna be a great father
that's really all I care about you know
my family my son my partner can't talk
about basketball business and and all
that but you know the focus is always on
just being a good person
[Music]